Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier
and welcome to "Lost in Vivo",
a horror game that's supposed to capitalize on
feelings of claustrophobia
So if you are claustrophobic,
buckle up, 'cause this is gonna be a fun ride.
And also I'm not 100% sure but I thiink
it might be by the same company...
as-ah it's a poopcher!
Pooper!
It is a poopy poop-cher!
Same company that did
Spooky's House of Jumpscares
I believe it's "Lag Studios", I'm pretty sure about that
Also it warned me at the beginning of the game there's a
symbol that will appear
when something is AFTER me
Ohh this is SO claustrophobic
Oh I know EXACTLY what it's talking about
Oh just the
the feel that-OH I'm getting flash backs from
Vanish.
Ohh I don't like that at all
Okay.
Here we go
Yeah the field of view is just
extremely skewed
To make you feel like
everything is way closer than it should be.
Oh geez.
Distances are all wrong.
Yeah
Okay
Well that one's all blocked off so
I guess I'll go down the illuminated path here.
Can I run?
Oh I can!
I can skedaddle a little bit
[Whistling]
I'm looking for my dog
[Distant, echoing bark]
Barf barf?
Barf barf-oh god
I didn't know I was gonna be looking for my dog!
Let's. Have.Three. Eyes.
How 'bout let's have two and call
it a day.
[Whistling]
[Two distant barks]
Bark bark!
Ohh no!
Chica!
Come back!
It's okay!
Oh Chica!
She's not in the room right now so
otherwise she'd be goin' crazy.
Ohh Chica!
[Whistling]
[Distant barks]
Rarf rarf!
Oh buddy buddy!
Ooh little buddy!
Oh I'm comin' for ya!
Oh no
Little buddy?
Is this a dead end? I can hardly tell with
how the field of view is
Oh
Teeth!
Oh good!
Yeah
We gonna have three teeth?
Three eyes? Three teeth? Three noses?
Three mouths?
[Whistling]
[Distant bark]
Ooh! Punchy!
Punchy ?
Poochy!
Chica cheekers! Cheeker squeakers!
Chunker bunkers!
Chunkles!
Get over here...
Okay
Oh, this doesn't look good
I also should mention that
this is just a demo
The full game is
uh trying to be kickstarted right now
I'll put a link in the description
[Mechanical sound]
OHHH THIS IS SO GOOD
OHH THIS IS SO GOOD
Sorry!
[Mechanical sound continues]
Oh
I was scared by a radio
It sounded like it was getting closer
because I was running by it
I'm an idiot okay I, I know that now
I'm an idiot I'm a big dumb
I am a dumbbb
Uuuh I don't like this
Yeh
I always know it's a good horror game when I
got that sense of dread
[Whistling]
[Distant barking]
Was that straight ahead?
Think it was straight ahead
Euh...
Euh
Okay
I think so!
Yeeeih!
Oh no
Poochers!
You betrayed me!
Poochers, you betrayed me!
[Whistling]
[Distant bark]
Poochers!
Why don't you just come to me, dangit!
Unless you're just as lost as I am
Which is probably the case
Oh poochers
whistling just in case
I probably shouldn't be
something else is out here
[Whistling anyway]
Uh
[Distant whistling back]
Aaaaaaaa-I...don't like that
[Whistling]
Chica no...
Oh I don't wanna go down this way
Ohh I don't want to go down this way!
[Quick, warped sound]
What was that...?
Oh
Was it the light flickering?
[Mark squeaking]
Oh. Is that blood or rust?
Meee
You're a kitty cat!
[Whistling]
Oh no
Oh no. Oh no. Ohh no.
Oh. Oh, is that meat?
In...the TV?
Why is there meat-oh,
someone was watchin' the old tele
[Whistling]
Okay
Ah
Oh please don't kill me
Oh good, a hammer
Can I use that?
Euh, who lives down here?
Okay
[Hammer-pick-up ding]
I got this
Hyah, for self defense
Hyeah, no one wants to mess with me
can I knock this down
Eih, eih
Woah, check out the wumpage on that
[Whistling]
Okay
There's no more
Chica's not responding
[Barking]
Oh, fucking hell
Hi!
Hello!
Hi-no!
Come back here!
Aww come on!
Ooh, heeeey
Is that Simon from "Cry of Fear"?
You better stay away from my pupper
You better stay away from my pup!
"I gave my eyes 2 the devil"
AH FUCK YE, FUCK
IT IS SIMON
FUCK YOU
GET FUCKED
YOU FUCKER
Yeah-KILL
[Periodic thumping]
He deserved it
I exploded him
Into meat
With my
mind
Yeah, you deserved it
He deserved it
Where'd the pooper go
[Whistling]
Pooper-pup?
Puppy pooper
That sounds really meaty
Okay
Oh this isn't good
Oh that's not good
Oh man, turning in here is so disorienting
Oh
Woah
Euh
Euh...
What is back there?
What's back there?
Is it what's gloob globbin'?
Oh it's what's gloobin' isn't it
I'll fight ya
Fight ya
Fight ya...
Glooby
[Thumping continuing]
Oh shit
Gloobs
Woah, woah woah woah woah
Woah
Something's wrong with that wall
Somethin' is wrong with this wall
Something tells me this wall's gonna disappear
and Immina be chased
[Quiet clanking]
[Thumping continuing]
Okay
Ah
Eh
Oh
Euh
Eiugh
Grooss
Oh no is someone over there too
I think so
Oh yeah someone's over there
Oh good
It's a cavalcade of horrors
[Markiplier sounds]
Egh
Okay
I wonder what would happen if I didn't
kill that guy
Puppy?
Poopers?
Chica?
Oh that doesn't sound good
[Warped, crescendo ringing]
Hi
Hello
Oh, okay
I'll just continue forward then
There doesn't seem to be any reason for me to look
[Airy sound]
Okay
Goodbye
Goodbye goodbye goodbye goodbye
[Small mechanical sounds]
Uhh I don't like that
All hope abandon ye who enter in
Oh good a maggoty pile of meat
So there was nothing over there
There was nothing over there
before I enter this sewer
Nope okay there's nothing
Immina go
Immina go now
Goin' forward
Oh
Visions
Visions bothered me
so I took them out
but they still worked!
I could still see!
So I ate them to make it stop but they're still...working
Please help me
Oh god
Curtis errrrx
Charon
Oh
Ah I just slipped right in
Eh, thought it was gonna be level transition or something
[Whistling]
Uh oh
I can't whistle anymore
[Whistling]
Oh there we go
[Growling noise}
Eih!
Okay
Immina-
[Growling]
Ohh
What is that
Oh what is that
Ohh what is that
I don't wanna know what that is
Okay
I..I, I might find out what that is
but I don't wanna know what that is
Eh
Eh..
Okay
Goodbye!
[Strange rattling sound]
Okay
[Rattling subsiding]
[Whistling]
Oh jesus ah
my god it's so easy-oh
Oh geez okay
Alright then
Ah good
Oh
Oh that's not nice
Well that's not nice
Ugh I'm...I'm starting to feel ill
Ah
Is that my blood or did I just splash in blood?
Think that was my blood
[Whistling]
Poochers!
[Ringing chime]
That doesn't sound-
THAT MEANS SOMETHING'S AFTER ME
THAT'S WHAT IT SAID IT SAID SOMETHING WAS AFTER ME
IT SAID THAT SOMETHING WAS AFTER ME
DIDN'T IT
THAT'S WHAT IT SAID AT THE BEGINNING OF THE GAME
Maybe you guys didn't see it
'Cause it was before I started recording that's why you guys didn't see it
[Tinging]
Ehhh
Ehhh...moodoodoodoo
[Whistling]
[Growling]
Eeaaauuagggh!
Ah!
Oh, hi
What are you?
Oh, what are you?
Ooh what are you?
What kind of sewer is this?
Oh what are you?
Oh is anything else here that I need to see
Oh god, it's so hard to look around
Yeeeih
I don't like this, whooh
My god
What is that squealing behind me?
Should I look? Probably not
[Grunting]
Oh, god
Eugh
Euh
[Growling]
Ey, woah, big guy
Okay
Alright then, you have fun there
Yeah I definitely think this was made by
the same guy that made "Spooky's House of Jumpscares" or the same people
Eh
[Staticy growl]
That's not good
Oh
Okay. AAAAAAHH
AAAAHH
Ow, ow
Ow. Get..get wrecked
Ah
Kill
Grr
Good, it deserved to die probably
Probably
Probably. Just theorizing
Put it out of it's misery and whatnot
[Whistling]
Poochers!
[Distant barking]
[Gasp]
Bark! Bark bark!
Bark bark bark!
Bark bark!
Bark bark?
[Gasp]
What!?
Whaaa come on, it was right there!
Aw poochers-aw man I would have gone down the other pathway!
Aw there was probably something else there!
Aw, man!
Huh, that was good, that was good though
oh man that kept me on the edge of my seat
That was really good
Dog question mark?
Oh
What are you trying to say there?
"Dog?" handler?
Ohh, dog question mark
"Why are you: even here?"
Good question
"None of: this matters" oh geez
Oh geez
"Nothing: matters"
Hoo
Hoo boy
"Was anything: real?"
"No,"
"Life isn't: real"
"You're not: real"
"I don't have: nightmares anymore"
"I can't see: them anymore"
"I don't: know"
"Did they: die?"
"Did I:die?"
I dunno
"The end happened a long time ago"
Oh
Oh man
Yeah
That was cool
That was really cool
and that was just a kickstarter demo
that could be it's own little horror game by itself
That's really cool
That was really cool, I have a lot of good things to say about this
but, again, this is just a demo
"It means something is after you! Sometimes it doesn't though, pay it no mind, it lies"-
Oh
"I'm the only one you can trust"
Ah
I didn't read ALL of that
Oh that was cool
and there's no options by the way
There's no options so
Thank you everybody so much for watching
I want a full game like this
This was really good
It was so, like
disorienting with the field of view, and
in the way that it was but I think that worked very well
to create a sense of unease
it was really really well done
and I like that a lot so
I'm gonna support this kickstarter
Eugh, there's a bug again..
and uh if you guys feel like it's worthy
you can play the demo for yourself
maybe there was some secret easter eggs that I didn't find
'cause I was too scared to go down certain paths!
So thanks again,
and as always, I will see you
in the next video!
Buh-bye!
[Horror outro]